so let's do a quick add-on to our story
about yesterday's debate I wanted to
separate the analysis of the content
from this story because this is kind of
its own thing so CNN fabricated they we
knew they were going to set up this
confrontation between Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren about the 2018 meeting
during which Bernie Sanders is accused
of saying a woman can't win Bernie
denied it CNN went on like Bernie had
admitted it and said to Warren how did
you feel when Bernie told you that even
though Bernie denied it after the debate
Bernie Sanders went over to Elizabeth
Warren extended his hand for a handshake
and Elizabeth Warren pulls her hand back
sort of surprising Bernie says something
while kind of wringing her hands then
Bernie kind of puts his hand out in a
whoa hold on a second way listens to the
next thing Warren says and eventually
does it kind of forget it hand signal
and turns around and walks away and of
course the question was which Tom Styer
was in a position to hear what was said
during that moment Bernie walking up
with the intention of shaking hands with
Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth Warren saying
something that stops Bernie short and
ultimately gets him to say forget this
turns around and walks away
Tom Styer was asked later what was said
he coyly said I didn't hear the
conversation I think that's him saying
I'm not getting into this he was
standing right there obviously he heard
it he was looking right at them and he
was inches away but he is probably
smartly staying the hell out of the way
of this so this actually is getting ugly
now now we we have to admit that there
is ugly on both sides here but it is not
equal ugly and I'm going to explain that
one of the things that was said for the
last couple of days was that after
Bernie got ugly with Warren after Bernie
sent supporters out to trash Warren that
Warren confirmed alleged that Bernie
said a woman can't win back in that
meeting in 2018 initially when it was
revealed that there were anti Warren
talking points being used by Bernie
staffers the Bernie campaign said these
were rogue staffers we did not authorize
these talking points that has fallen
apart and
I would be doing something dishonest if
I didn't tell you this the Bernie
Sanders camp has now confirmed that they
were indeed using an anti Warren script
in multiple early states and it's
important because this is different than
the initial story that was told if it is
untrue that Bernie said a woman can't
win it's disgustingly immoral to accuse
him of that but now that Bernie has
admitted that the Sanders campaign did
utilize this anti Warren script and at
least a couple of early voting states
there is something else here that Warren
can rightly be critical of Bernie for
doing but here's the thing if you come
to me and you say David please
adjudicate what's worse is using an anti
Warren script when campaigning worse or
is falsely claiming that Bernie said a
woman can't win worse well if it's a lie
claiming that Bernie said a woman can't
win is worse for sure because the
reality is that the anti Warren script
that Bernie deployed framing Elizabeth
Warren as the candidate for the educated
elites it's not morally wrong to do that
this is politics now the issue is Bernie
and Warren seem to have agreed back in
2018 not to attack each other and by
deploying the anti Warren script Bernie
Sanders broke his agreement with
Elizabeth Warren that's between them
though right that's for them to figure
out this is politics scripts that go
after other candidates during phone
banking and door-knocking
are used all the time the issue for us
to figure out because our priority is
removing Donald Trump is whether any of
this helps us do that when Bernie
Sanders uses a script that attacks
Elizabeth Warren in early States does
that jeopardize the likelihood of
removing Donald Trump if Bernie is not
ultimately the nominee maybe it does
when a story is put out by CNN with or
without confirmation by Elizabeth Warren
we don't know coordination with
Elizabeth Warren rather she confirmed it
but was there coordination there we
don't know if neither burning or warren
are the nominees what does the
this dust-up do for our chance to defeat
Donald Trump that's why I've said from
the beginning I do not want this to get
ugly in a way that helps Donald Trump
it's starting to get ugly in a way that
may help Donald Trump now I'll be honest
I think all of this scandal this week
does nothing to propel Bernie nor
Elizabeth Warren into first place and by
so buying time for Joe Biden to remain
in first place it positions Biden to
start winning primaries which may have
been the goal of all of this thing from
the beginning let me know what you think
I'm on Twitter follow me there and send
me a message letting me know what you
think is the ultimate goal of all of
this and who is the real catalyst for
this is this an establishment plan is
this a war an establishment plan is it a
warren Biden plan is it truly just
innocent stories coming to light
increasingly that's hard to believe let
me know what you think I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman